yo people it's H and right now I'm about
to talk to myself
hello me I know right alright how are
you good and what did you do to escape
Fame and the music and to escape music
what do I do
yeah to be on it this year this year and
I've no no escape it's just been me
black music every day and yeah the plan
is to just to just not even go on
holiday and we just go hold my chest off
I hey do you know that stuff that's
gonna be the escape escape oh yeah I got
time to escape from there for a bit I'll
escape in about four years and what is
it what do you do when you do nothing
well I say that I'm going to sit in my
house and I'll be sat there for about
two hours and then get bored and then
going out I'll go into the studio or
something so musics just there all the
time but you know what's mad yeah escape
from use it I go to the studio I just
don't do anything
it's be there typical ladies you stage
name come from my stage name came from
my real name your name into the h/h you
know why god yeah okay interesting
yeah so where do you see each other five
years time five years time I'm gonna be
the biggest artists in the UK I respect
it I thought it would take me four or
five years to get here and it took a
year so in five years
see you later yeah
who's your biggest inspiration different
people for different reasons
I would say Bugsy Malone's an
inspiration mm Sam I'm from Manchester
yeah yes just blew up and made well
however much money and however much
I'm a fan bases major I mean Latin huh
it didn't ignite didn't seem possible
what he was no evidence of it being
impossible
obviously Stephan inspiration and what
was the first moment when you realized
he was famous before I drop straight
rhymes I won like 7,000 followers and
now I'm on like 800,000 in a year wow I
thought rah yeah I'm famous you know me
there's 101 you think you got don't
think it hits you until you actually
look at the facts and I'll look up the
evidence there in front of you I mean
and what's the best thing about being
famous not in it in a little you know in
a window okay I think I'm higher than
anyone else way but a lot of people try
to like be on your good side all the
times in it yeah complete with that no
I'm saying mmm
what was the high point in your career
so far
top 5 get the top five with taste yeah
again the top 5 that's been the maddest
that's been the - to me and it's even
more magazine doing expensive see how
I'm saying that was just a littler even
I feel like I said this twice straight
Rome's was meant to be a warm-up for
something Wow and it ended up blowing me
up and then taste was meant to be a
warm-up for the EP and it went and got
up five minute so I'm just going to
start making their warm-up jeans and how
did you tell about this at five
I didn't yeah yeah I did it yeah I will
who would you want to collaborate we
have to end our life do I always say dig
that I just picked me and dig that make
a six you like at the moment at this
moment I'm not off my head to dig that
but and being a fun fifth get all day
long you could only listen to what album
for the rest of your life what would it
be I choose my EP it's two old boys
apart to that I choose get rich or die
trying' fifty Sam right that's it for
most people did you die you interview
yeah good thank you very much I like you
chain this but you're a little
you